what is it that you most want for
Christmas this year not just not just
presents because Santa I think will have
you covered if you stay a good boy but
what do you want to to do here with your
family what do you want to see happen
for the Muir family you're the you're
the man of the house
it's always fantastic when we can give
back look and I know what you're
thinking don't skip don't skip some very
important information we just wanted to
take this last opportunity to make sure
that we do not lose touch with you if
you are a mug Club subscriber right now
or if you want to join mug Club please
go to mugclubforever.com enter your
email address you will get no other
communication from us but make sure that
you go there there's no other reason to
be subscribed on that list unless you
are a mug Club member or you want to be
a mug Club member make sure you follow
us on social we'll have all the updates
there just about other information as we
take some time here to figure out where
mug Club will be going but we love you
guys we want you to have a fantastic
time and what better way to end the year
than to make sure we give a little back
and
on with the show
what's this what's this this candle's
everywhere what's this
what's this I can't believe my eyes are
being dropped and sodomized right who's
there what's this
what's this what's this this all sounds
very wrong seven principles too long
what's this Street's a line of people
doing God knows what using Blackness as
a crush am I going nuts what is this
what's this
when the children are done playing
they'll climbing through their beds get
fat a lot of crap from the stories they
all read ilfano I can't believe the lies
did they mention all the girls he
drugged and beat
oh look the two people who celebrate
this day the cleaning isn't fake they're
white because no one black really likes
this holiday you asking but they say
what's this
oh look in here
a little derivative to me and hate don't
they realize that Ron ever [ __ ] Even
Called Jesus psychotic is there anyone
who bought it I'm not honest looks like
[ __ ] this looks like he was a racist
what's this
oh look the kids they made their guanza
wish but someone who stole their Kwanza
gifts I kid but can you please just tell
me why you praised a guy who always
tries to tell you this isn't your home
oh
what's this
he'll tell you of its value and the
house support is strong but tell me can
you even name a single Kwanzaa song
you'd say it's like that Christmas and
I'd say that's quite a leap why do
people sit here and listen to this
please just let me leave this Horror in
place I'd like to go home right away you
know it's wrong to face a holiday on
race and tell people to love a place
you've never been you'll never go you
know it's not your home I want to go I
want you going
out what is this
[Music]
Kwanzaa town
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
oh my
it is hard to do that sip when look at
all the marshmallows
in there that makes it difficult we
almost just had to give Santa Crowder a
tracheotomy but
it's Christmas so everyone gets to keep
their jobs this year it's also scalding
hot
it's delicious and that
I believe
secretarcoco.com and I assure you that
uh I stand to not make a penny from it
it's coffee brand coffee uh company uh
but they do Coco just rebranded so it's
easy for you to find with a URL I highly
recommend it I've never had anything
better I have to take off this glove too
look
this is something that we do every year
here uh at the louder with Crowder
Studio where we do
just a little part that we can to give
back if you're looking for politics
this is not the place for you today
you're looking for hot takes
they're right out
this is just about highlighting some
people and families and and stories and
hopefully helping some people out there
who need a little assistance making
their Christmas miracle happen so we're
going to be highlighting some of those
families who we went out to help this
year some Charities and we're going to
have some special guests calling in to
wish all of you mug clubbers a Merry
Christmas and of course none of this is
possible without your assistance and
signing up at mugclub forever.com but
you already knew that
so we have some I have a list here of
people oh we'll have special guests Dean
Kane Clint Howard uh Jason Whitlock
Michael Knowles and
Ben Shapiro
well everyone's welcome
good for you taking part we really
appreciate it so most importantly we'll
be trying to bless some families and
organizations in need and we have a
couple of
well two very specific families later on
in this program who I think will
if nothing else give you a little
appreciation for what you have this year
and take some time to
help spread some Christmas cheer to
those around you I know that all of us
have our troubles we have our thing to
deal with but
and there's someone else who could maybe
use a hand and sometimes thinking about
them and focusing on their needs and
what you can do to meet them well makes
That season just a little bit more
meaningful before we get to that though
here are some other families we visited
to deliver toys now as you well know uh
Santa sleigh is in the shop it's really
just a one time a year thing so they had
to send in uh their videos we did
deliver toys for their family and some
assistance but
they did it by him
Zoom correct
okay let's roll it
roll it oh
what would you like for Christmas a new
hoverboard
a VR headset
um pasta pens alcohol markers room
decorations and clothes
[Music]
Pokemon cards and we're in guitar app I
like my mobile blocks fireman ambulance
and police I just want an iPad I want I
okay I want something 80s themed I think
that'd be really fun accessory socks and
a construction buildable construction
vehicles uh airsoft Glock pistol a new
headset what do you want for Christmas
[Music]
what do you want for Christmas Minecraft
[Music]
what does your sister want for Christmas
uh she wants a makeup desk a makeup desk
you want Christmas what does Christmas
mean to you celebrating Jesus's birthday
and all coming together amazing world
baby Jesus and family Christmas Means to
Me spending time with family and friends
and getting to celebrate them
the day that Jesus was born with them
Christmas Means to Me spending time with
my family going to church on Christmas
Eve and playing in the snow
um to spend time with family and friends
and also
um to worship Jesus because it's his
birthday Joy love free friends and
family to get there and
it's already the birth of our savior
it's today Jesus is born and it gives us
time to fellowship with friends and
family celebrating Jesus's birthday
surprise it's Jesus birthday and
spend time with families and care about
Jesus
okay Christmas means spending time with
family
decorating the Christmas tree and
drinking hot cocoa spending time with
their family it will be our family
family fun and oh so oh
thank you very much we appreciate you
taking the time to read our emails and
bye bye say bye bye Merry Christmas
letters Crowder
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so naughty we have David
we have Zachary
they're all Jews
and on nice we have
yay okay
I told you to stop playing pranks on
Santa it's a violation of your
employment contract uh at least you know
know what on this list ended up as
weird as one of my last elves uh Hermie
before Christmas and everybody is
getting ready for that big sleigh ride
on the night of the 24th Christmas Eve
see all these toys are made by these
elves these elves have that certain
knack for toy making all except for this
this one Misfit
[Music]
Herbie aren't you finished painting that
yet
there's a pile up a mile behind you
what's eating your boy well see that's
the problem I guess what what I just
don't like being a boy how well is that
song
what you don't like being a boy now
Hermie doesn't like being a boy honey
doesn't like being a boy Hermie doesn't
like being a boy he doesn't like being a
boy
telling me what you do wanna be well sir
someday I'd like to be a a lady a lady
well we need one up here see I've been
studying and there's hormone blockers
and bottom transition surgery and fake
no listen you you're a boy L and Boyle
stay boy now get to work
[Music]
10 minute breaks
[Applause]
not for you
finish the job or you're fired
[Music]
why is he such a trans foe I can't stand
wearing men's clothes shop my golf with
God Stowe then I might fit in
oh
that was weird now on to my favorite
part of the program it's time for
Crowder gives back
oh oh what's that I hear are those
carols at Santa Crowder's door
Christmas I mean I grew up in America
Christmas is not just a Christian
holiday it's it's sort of an American
holiday that does not mean that I
celebrate Christmas but the sort of
Christmas spirit that pervades the
season is really fun and enriching and
endearing for I think everybody who
lives in the United States you have to
celebrate the holiday to appreciate the
spirit of the Season what does Christmas
mean to me uh well obviously it means
the birth of Christ it is uh very very
touching to me a lot of people complain
that you know Christmas has a lot of
pagan uh symbolism in it like the
Christmas tree and things and maybe it's
a pagan holiday uh but I to me that's a
feature not a bug Christian Christianity
should christianize everything it
touches and if you have a wonderful
holiday and uh some wonderful traditions
and they become begin to represent
Christ that's a good thing I mean I know
I'm talking to Crowder's uh audience so
you're a bunch of troglodytes who are
punching yourself repeatedly in the face
just because you want to find out what
it feels like but obviously I think it's
an important idea if you can possibly
understand it uh that Christianity
christianizes the world and so Christmas
with its pagan uh rituals in it uh is a
wonderful thing that just shows How
Deeply Christianity transforms
everything uh into joy and also you get
presents what does Christmas mean to me
uh it means the birth of our Lord and
savior and the Incarnation of the second
person of the Holy Trinity what
Christmas really means to me
great food
growing up I've had some feasts of
Feasts on Christmas looking forward to
pigging out you know you got that
diabetic coma going on in the afternoon
real good Christmas spirit and in all
honesty what Christmas really means to
me is the birth of my faith
you know we all have faith I have faith
and I take a moment on Christmas Eve
Christmas day to go back and reflect
on the birth of my faith our favorite
Christmas tradition
um
would be would be Mama yeah yeah mama
mama love Christmas Miss Hall oh she
love Christmas she she did the most you
could possibly do with no money and
still make Christmas great for for our
kids man like Mama on Christmas Eve that
turkey man mama get this turkey you want
a big turkey it's like a damn hand but
like I said she did the most with a
little butter we had that damn hand with
no more than two three pounds I matter
of fact looking back when I think it was
a Cornish hen in it but anyway oh what
Accord is he in but anyway Mama cooked
the turkey uh uh Christmas Eve night
cook it slow man yeah she could cook
that turkey for three days
no she'll cook it at night a slower man
Mama take your time with that turkey man
no she would cook the turkey that's
three days man yeah she'll cook that
turkey that night and over uh Christmas
Eve night the turkey you could when you
sleeping in the bed yeah think about
what Santa Claus gonna bring us all you
can smell is that damn turkey now stop
now you know we won't get nothing from
Santa Claus what does Christmas mean to
me Christmas Means well obviously if
you're celebrating the birth of Jesus
Christ
um if you want to be religious about it
if you don't want to
um it's just family getting together
being with the love the ones you love
that's just the greatest thing ever
um that that that's Christmas Is To Me
family together time to reminisce and be
together well pogroms now
oh yeah also yeah my neighbor's night's
our next level that's
that's in the block and this person goes
actually there's sort of a Christian
Jewish War happening like there are two
houses right next door to each other and
one has a bunch of conical lights that
I'm sure will put up just in direct
opposition to the Christmas lights
because the Christmas lights are
overwhelming I mean it looks like a
state fair and so I think so there's a
Jewish Family who lives next door and
they're like we're gonna put a bunch of
blue and white lights the fight is on
what does Christmas mean to me now
probably means what it's always meant to
me except now I have a better
understanding of it when I was a kid
obviously Christmas meant great gifts
and new clothes and a bunch of food
[Music]
it means to me now it's a reminder of
God of Jesus greatest gift to us and
that's family
Christmas is a great time to commune
celebrate Fellowship engage with your
family and to remind yourself
that Jesus died on the cross for our
sins and his greatest gift to us was
found hey let me say to all of you
people who got stuck with those horrible
Crowder mugs Merry Christmas uh you know
I actually love Stephen and you know
when he slides down in your chimney
don't open fire on him just call the
police from the Knowles family to all of
you out there in mug Club I wish you a
very merry Christmas hey Merry Christmas
Stephen merry Christmas everybody
Merry Christmas
from the Halls to his whole whole whole
whole
Merry Christmas mug Club Merry Christmas
mug club and make sure to give a daily
wire subscription to all those who love
you so that I can you know have some
more shackles we love you mug Club have
a great Christmas
[Music]
okay no more interruptions that's rude
it makes the naughty list and why is
Santa's hat so
my forehead it looks like
looks like Santa Christina Ricci doesn't
it
let's deliver some Christmas Joy it's
time for my favorite part in Crowder
gives back
[Music]
I like that that Stinger that's a lot
better than than Gerald knows stuff and
if you all go out to uh mugclub
forever.com of course you know you can
expect more great content in the future
but you already knew that this doesn't
happen if not for you so first we have
Mika and Kara Muir and their children
Josh Caitlin Samuel Isabella and Gracie
with a very special story I'm sure will
touch your hearts
[Music]
oh there they are
there's them your family oh boy can can
everyone sorry sometimes this has
changed with the you know the pandemic
save some people want me to do this with
the the Skype or FaceTime condom your
can you all see me
oh I can see all of you wow look at that
look at that troop there's so many of
you okay now hold on don't don't tell me
we know we we know the the mom and dad
that's that's Mika and Cara but what
really matters is we have let's see I
know
you if I point you may not know who I'm
here let me take off my gloves it gets a
little clammy in here anyways we have
Samuel Samuel razor oh very oh Samuel's
already a comedian I see
how are you Sam you you enjoying your
Christmas season thus far
yes sir yes sir well you should you can
just call me Santa but I for your
parents oh good job me couldn't care
good job with the manners I appreciate
that you know not all little boys have
good manners sometimes they uh they
actually pull pranks on Santa I ripped
my pants last year
[Applause]
well I'm glad you had a laugh at uh my
my dry cleaner didn't now we have uh
where's Josh Josh I I'm looking here
Josh right there is that okay that's
Josh so that must mean that you Isabella
right there and
right there hi Isabella how are you
sweetheart
okay good are you having a good
Christmas
yes okay good look at you I see you
you're just such a gorgeous family and
then we must have we have little we have
Gracie is that right oh Gracie right
we have Gracie okay and then you must be
last but certainly not we have Caitlyn
right is that Caitlin
oh you you look younger than Caitlyn if
I'm not missed you are you oh don't
don't tell me you're 11 now right
yes sir you well see on my screen right
now you're so small that you you look
about three years old uh Santa's used to
to using analog technology more but I'm
so glad to see all of you what a
wonderful family now do you know that
your your parents actually specifically
called Santa this year and said oh my
family would love to get on a call with
Santa could you please do it so they
really think a whole lot of you children
you should make sure to be good thank
your mom and dad for me can you thank
you
you're welcome good and that's that's
always Mom and Dad we don't do the first
name basis with our parents right Mika
Mika and Kara how are you doing this
year thank you so much for reaching out
and and making this happen
thank you guys we're doing good
thank you for calling us absolutely I
know that you've had obviously some some
tougher times here this this last year
but uh Gracie I'm so glad to see the
Gracie uh is is back home I know Gracie
spent some time right in the in the
hospital
and it seems like Gracie's doing better
she's he she was doing it to I believe
surgery in Dallas but she's home for the
she's home for Christmas this year
she is we spent four months in the
hospital but she's doing well well
that's fantastic I'm so glad to see that
is everyone there you all you all
helping Mom and Dad with Gracie right
now
yes sir Josh Josh you're the next man of
the house are you helping with with
Gracie helping Mom and Dad because I
know it's not easy oh oh look at that
Samuel says no
Samuel is Josh abdicating his duties
no is he he's a pretty good Big Brother
Josh
yes
oh Samuel come on now remember you have
to tell the truth otherwise we have that
naughty list
we don't really do coal anymore it's
more so you know fracking based these
days but uh
the principle's the same all right I
want to talk with each one of you first
let's let's go I guess from oldest to
youngest because uh sometimes that's how
it went old older siblings sometimes
they get bored because they're used to a
screen everywhere so Josh are you uh are
you still PL are you still playing
basketball is that do you I I understand
I remember you used to be very into it
yes basketball well let me let me ask
you Josh are you more into basketball I
also understand from your parents that
you're very into science experiments is
that is that true
yes okay so if you have to pick your
career do you think you're going to be a
future Lebron or whatever a good version
of fault she is
basketball
okay so aside from I know you like
basketball and I know that you know
science there's a lot we can do with
that very important that we have
scientists here in this country and
Engineers there's no country without
them but you still ride like to have
some fun is the the Nerf guns things
like that still the types of things you
like to play with
yes sir okay well that's something you
know Santa was back in the day we didn't
have all of these new toys so it was
pretty much baseball bats hula hoops we
didn't have Nerf guns we had cork guns
do you know what cork guns were do you
know what that is
there you go it's pretty much like a
Nerf gun only you know from your parents
empty wine bottles you'd put it in
there'd be some pressure and you'd shoot
it out and we all had fun but uh it
would not pass safety standards these
days so let me ask you
Josh what is it that you most want for
Christmas this year not just not just
presents because Santa I think will have
you covered if you stay a good boy but
what do you want to to to do here with
your family what do you want to see
happen for the Muir family you're the
you're the man of the house
you want to see Gracie get better
do you hear that Mom and Dad
that's a that's not just a nice son
that's a that's what we call a good man
Josh and you know what she's going to do
better the more that you put in effort
and help your mom and dad and take care
of all your brothers and sisters that
makes their life a lot easier and I tell
you I've been following what has been
going on with Gracie and it it breaks
Santa's heart but it fills Santa's heart
with joy to know that she's back home
for the holidays so do you promise
you'll you'll keep helping your mom and
dad and take care of everyone not just
Gracie because that helps her too
absolutely okay well Josh thank you is
there anything else you'd like to ask
santa before I move on
are you sure you don't have to be so
formal right we can be on you couldn't
be on a first name basis with Santa just
not Mom and Dad
well Josh if you can think of anything
I'll I'll go back okay now I think that
I believe though it's hard for me to see
again a small screen but Caitlyn right
oh Caitlin I can see you right there now
Caitlin do you have is that your natural
hair color or do you put streaks in in
your hair do you diet at all
oh okay do you do that yourself or does
mommy help
and I go get my hair done
oh okay you do you Outsource we do some
of that at the North Pole sometimes the
elves can only work so many hours a day
so if you find a good person it's worth
its weight in gold and do you still
really like doing that do I know you
like doing hair makeup and I can see you
like wearing stylish clothes is that
still really something you're into
yes sir okay well look that's something
that I I have to tell you all little
girls almost all the requests are for
things like hair straighteners or hair
dye or makeup and the only thing that I
ask is whatever it is that Santa gets
for you this year assuming you've been
good is that you make sure Mommy and
Daddy are supervising because sometimes
there can be harsh chemical burns do you
promise you promise that to Santa
Caitlyn
yes sir okay and Caitlyn tell me tell me
specifically what is it that you would
like from Santa this year
bicycle okay are we talking mountain
bike speed bike are you a hipster who
likes one of those fixies with a large
front wheel
oh everything's going electric okay so
we have a bicycle
what what else would you like Caitlyn
what else are you hoping for this
Christmas
a vanity mirror
thing
um
hold on a second good good children
don't interrupt but I understand it's
very exciting at Christmas you know
vanity mirrors
Santa avoids them
yes maybe two three hundred years ago
but now sometimes I look at them and I
don't recognize the face anymore so I
mostly just try and focus on the
laughter I bring
to others
all right let's uh move on down now I
heard you just start speaking so Samuel
you've been very patient but Samuel are
you okay if I speak with Isabella first
because I know she's she's she's
champing at the bit all right thank you
Samuel that's a gentleman okay Isabella
I couldn't hear you so well what was
that you just said
you did did you just say you want a
doggy
well maybe you mean a dog like Max
because that would be theft
I think you mean a dog like Max right
we just have to how about this stuff
oh you want us you want a stuffed dog oh
well Santa you know before I became
Santa I was a taxidermist that's right
up my alley that's no problem at all so
Isabella okay you want a stuffed dog I
understand you like stuffed animals of
all different kinds right because that's
okay so what what maybe things like a
like like stuffed bunnies uh maybe I
know there are you I like bunnies you
like bunnies
you also wants some clothes right maybe
some kind of maybe some kind of ankle
boots Maybe
yes I don't know if you can see this
here but Santa wears these old ankle
boots they're kind of oh but the only
problem is sometimes Santa if he gets on
a flight for too long gets thrombosis
so
I know all about boots what about things
like I know you like things like kinetic
sand and toys like that too or is it
just is that something you also like to
play with
I like I want green sand you want green
sand
okay well that's not too hard to come by
I think that's something maybe we can do
now have you been a have you been a good
girl this year
yeah how how have you been good have you
been helping out the family
okay my mom and dad can you confirm that
oh yes sir and grace are your best
friend she helps with Gracie all the
time oh that's wonderful I'm so happy to
hear it okay well Isabella I'm going to
speak with your brother now who's been
waiting I know how hard it is to be
patient
Samuel there he is Samuel I know don't
tell me are you you're you're eight
years old now right
okay and and Sam do you still really
like because keep in mind sometimes
Santa has to keep track of billions of
children across the world but I have a
pretty good memory that's one of I'll
call it a gift that I have you you still
love building things but also taking
them down is that something you're still
really into you know what's really cool
now you can have these drones that you
can build yourself sometimes and then
you can fly them have you have you have
you used a drone is that something you
still want
okay so you haven't used them but you
you want a drone right
that's on your list I do have I don't
have it written down I have it right up
in the old eggnoggin
now like your brother do you would you
like maybe because your brother right
here you need someone to play with some
Nerf guns too so maybe you could play
together
okay so we have a drone we have Nerf
Nerf guns I know you all need clothes
everyone needs clothes but that's not
always fun that's kind of a given what
else Samuel what else would you like to
ask Santa for this year
a motorcycle
a motorcycle well that's going to be a
hard pass until you're of legal age
that's one of those things I I you know
Santa Santa has his own motorcycle I
don't know if you know that every again
the sleigh gets all depressed but are
you sled dogs and motorcycles no SUV no
cage for Santa
so when you get older that's a
discussion with your parents though you
have to take if you ever ride a
motorcycle okay do you promise you'll
wear your helmet and only if your
parents say that you can you promise
oh boy oh Isabella was what what were
you doing there you look like you were
going to grab your brother was that a
hug
that better have been a hug what else uh
Samuel is there anything else specific
you would really like for Christmas this
year beyond what we've covered because I
think that's something that's certainly
in my wheelhouse what do you think
Gracie would like this year Samuel is
she still playing with dolls and toy
animals things like that yeah okay
I'll do this
um they make her better you make you
make Gracie's bed
make it better
it's not sick oh you want Gracie to get
better so she's not sick I know
sometimes it's very very hard to deal
with that we've had that you know
sometimes here in the claws family and
it's very important that you help your
parents and of course I'm sure you say
your prayers Gracie's been making a lot
of progress I've been following it and I
think she's going to continue getting
better but it's very very important for
everyone here okay Caitlin Isabella Josh
Samuel that you always keep up hope and
you always stick together as a family
right everyone understand that
okay that's very important because toys
and gifts and yes Santa's going to come
to your house this year and I think
you'll be very happy but nothing
replaces the importance of family and
helping each other you never get another
one so make sure you do that for each
other and that's going to help Gracie as
much as possible okay okay all right
well little ones thank you so much and
and Gracie you'll get better I don't can
Gracie talk with Santa's Gracie tired if
Gracie's tired I don't want to
she's tired and nervous okay
super shy well Gracie's been through a
lot so okay everyone look do do me one
favor here the little ones I need to
speak with your parents but before you
leave I want to see all of you give
Gracie either a hug or a kiss and if
you're good here for the rest of the
year Santa's going to be hopefully
seeing some happy faces Christmas
morning give give her a big kiss
oh there you go Samuel get in there
everyone come on get some of that
kissing kissing Gracie sister action
Good Hugs work too
bye Josh by Samuel oh look he's got the
oh I remember when I lost my teeth that
was half a millennia go bye Caitlyn bye
Isabella thank you so much oh Mom and
Dad this is this is a special year
ones are out so we can talk just just us
adults
we are good all right oh well thank you
so much for reaching out Mr and Mrs Muir
now now now Mika I understand that you
you're obviously you're you're a pastor
that's that's what you do right
yes sir and you also teach on the side
I did until she went to the hospital
right and can you ex from what I
understand uh Gracie you know Santa
knows this with a lot of children uh Had
A congenital uh issue
um and uh this also of course you Foster
many children and this may have been you
know something that happened that could
have been lineal uh passed down to her
correct
certainly right and she she went to
Dallas Texas for heart surgery it didn't
quite go as planned but she's been
actually improving and she's she's just
this weekend she came home with you
yes okay
yes
um yeah she
um
so it's called dextrocardia and it's
back and it splits backwards and so she
has other things going on but uh so yeah
the surgery was a normal routine
um ideally should have been our last
open heart surgery but it didn't go well
so they had to take that down
and did a second heart surgery kidneys
liver shut down we've had other issues
with lungs pulmonary
um we discovered she has pulmonary
hypertension she's on a medicine that is
basically keeping her alive and so it's
through a pump so we're real careful
with that obviously and um but she's
going to continue getting better and
eventually we'll have a heart transplant
oh absolutely and I know I know how
difficult that can be but boy am I glad
to know that she's in your care because
we both know and for people who are out
there that you know there are a lot of
children who need foster care and need
homes for them and so many people don't
open them up and for you to open your
home and your hearts and and help her
that means the world to me that's that's
every bit as much as what Santa can do
so thank you so much I appreciate that
and I know so you you know I think
you've already spoken with Santa's elves
and Santa's been following what's been
going on with Gracie and I I know that
you know this is why I wanted to make
sure the children are out that Santa's
going to take care of the Christmas
lists this year you both know that right
yes sir but thank well I I thank you for
reaching out you know and I I want you
to there's also one more surprise that
we have for you and that's because I
know how difficult it can be especially
when one of you you know you can't work
Health Care can be so difficult and
expensive and so I'd like to bring in my
elf Riley here for you right now
here Santa has a surprise for you you
may not be able to see it can elves can
they see this yet no I'll bring this in
here
Santa is going to be sending you a check
for fifty thousand dollars to help with
Gracie and anything that you need here
for the rest of the year
and I promise you this is symbolic but
it's it's right as rain I can wire it
and Santa's never had a check bounce
uh
oh Cara thank you so much Riley Kara
Mika
we appreciate you so much and I I wish
that I could do all of the things for
you I wish I could fix it but there's
only so much I can do and I I sincerely
I pray for you and I I really hope this
helps
and we love you here so much it means so
much that you've reached out and how
much you care about your family and
family that you've taken in
I hope people who see this can just use
you as an example
thank you so much what an unbelievable
blessing oh it's I tell you what the
blessing is all mine all year you know
the world can be difficult in an ugly
place and everyone everyone goes through
difficulties everyone has their own
hurdles but your story really spoke to
us here at the North Pole and I promise
we're going to send that over to you and
and if there's anything else that that
we can do to help with please let us
know if you have a message to people
watching Kara thank you that's your I
hope those are tears of joy and not the
fact that Santa can't just cash out six
figures I can't take a second mortal
[ __ ]
browser they're definitely to enjoy and
the Lord has blessed us and um allowed
us to take care of his children
um
he's given us children that
while we never thought we'd even have so
we have ten
um
and um I've had many more through the
you know we have black biological
children we've adopted five and
but Foster here is huge and a huge um
really special to our heart and so but
y'all's blessing y'all's gift is a huge
blessing to our family
well thank you so much you've been a
blessing to us and I think you'll be a
blessing to more people out there than
you know hearing your story and seeing
what a wonderful family you have I know
how hard it can be going through these
times but the hope that you have and the
love you have for your family is well
that's really what Christmas is about
right we have the original example for
God so loved the world he sent his only
son it was a dark time and now we all
have all have hope in him and I do think
that you'll also give people hope when
they hear your story and I just am so
grateful to have played even just a
small part in it
certainly thank
you thankful more than you can ever
imagine
um
well I'll tell you this they're not
showing anyone else here because there's
not a dry eye in the house everyone is
so happy for you we do have to get going
for another family uh Mika and Kara and
uh the only thing is that the check does
come with a drug testing policy so be
sure to be careful with that
thank you both miors thank you so much
Merry Christmas to you and yours and God
bless you keep us posted
Merry Christmas
[Music]
I guess that's a little bit of Christmas
magic and I thank you from the back of
my scalded heart now not many people
know this but every year Santa Crowder
actually makes a few house calls before
Christmas Eve
and what some would call a co-sier Santa
and this year I visited Prestonwood
Pregnancy Center and Cat Casa Casa
that's that's Spanish Santa should know
this we're multilingual at the North
Pole
Prestonwood Pregnancy Center and Casa
Colin County and because I'm busy I
actually sent some Elves out to deliver
some Christmas cheer in the form of tens
of thousands of dollars of Cold Hard
Cash that's not I don't mean Santa cash
and it's not like coals where I Mark
something up by 25 to mark it down by 10
and tell you that you've saved 70 this
is real cash delivered Hand by elves to
the Charities that phrase doesn't make
just enjoy it all right we are out here
at the Prestonwood Pregnancy Center with
a staff nurse named Whitney correct all
right so Whitney if you don't mind could
you just tell us a little bit about what
your organization does for the community
sure
um we are a pregnancy center and we help
women in crisis we have free pregnancy
tests free sonograms we do STD testing
we have counselors on site we have a
resource center across the street as
well so
um it just can help anybody who is in a
crisis pregnancy
um to know what all their options are
and to help them make a life-affirming
decision so I don't know if you're aware
but Santa has also got wind of your
organization and the good that you do
for the community so he sent us out and
actually sent a couple of his l out and
we're gonna present you with something
that hopefully you can use during the
Christmas season so
yeah so that is a check for 75 000 that
we thought you all could put to
excellent use yes amazing that is a real
signature
you have no idea the number of women
that you're gonna bless with this so
thank you
wow Santa thank you where could people
reach out to you if they want to find
your services what's a good website sure
prestonwoodpregnancy.org thank you once
again we appreciate it
all right we are here with Theresa
Brooke and Trish who is the CEO of Casa
of Collin County and if you could could
you just tell our viewers a little bit
about what your organization stands for
and what you do as a part of the
community sure so we are Casa Colin
County and we are the court appointed
special Advocates
um basically what that is is we train
volunteers like yourself in the
community to represent the children who
have been abused or neglected and
removed from their homes and placed into
the child welfare system well that
sounds like a really worthwhile cause
and we're not the only ones that think
so Santa actually thought the same thing
unfortunately he's really busy as you
can imagine back at the North Pole but
he sent us out because he's heard so
many nice things about your organization
that he wanted to help in any way he
could so actually if you don't mind our
elves brought a little something from
Santa if we could present that to you
now
[Music]
oh my God so that is amazing
so we hope that you can use that we
absolutely can you have no idea how much
this means to not just us but to the
community and the children that we serve
this will go so far in allowing us to
serve every single child that is
affected by abuse and neglect in our
County so thank you so much
oh my gosh I'm speechless that doesn't
really happen if there's anybody that
wants to become part of this
organization or wants to get in touch
with your organization where can they
find you or should they reach out
um so you can go to
www.casaofcollandcounty.org you can find
out what it means to be an advocate how
you could become an advocate or how else
you can help out Merry Christmas
oh I'm glad that was a pre-tape because
it is hard to keep it together of course
everyone has touched here this time of
year but of course if you saw how I
really felt and I lost it I'd be
unprofessional and Mrs Claus would tell
me I need to grow a spine
so finally we actually have a very
special family and that's uh the sharps
mama and papa Tasha and Nick and their
children Samuel Jojo and Billy and a
very important story about one of their
children Benny
[Music]
oh
there they are all the way from oh from
Maryland is that where is that where I'm
I'm talking with you right now
yeah yeah okay I know can everyone say
give me your family name everyone I'm
going to I'm taking off my glove
what's what's your family name
what's our last name Bud shops the
sharps and you're a sharp one two okay
so you must be I know Mom and Dad that's
that's Nick and Tasha Nick you know
that's my that's my name people know me
as Santa Claus but do you know the story
of Saint Nicholas
oh smart little one so we have Nicholas
for the purposes of this interview I'm
going with Nicholas
Tasha and you must be Samuel if I
remember is that right Samuel
now do you prefer you still go by Sammy
yeah yes okay well I know you know on my
list I have your name but then I have a
nickname that's we still call them
nicknames which is we don't go Nicholas
names we have Sammy then we have
Jonathan
if I'm okay we have Jonathan and it's
hard for me to see in a little screen oh
there's there's Little Billy
there's Little Billy look at little
Billy Oh Billy seems like Billy's hungry
huh
oh well I hope look I I know Billy's a
growing girl but make sure you save some
of that for Santa on Christmas night
Sammy are you going to be the one to
leave out the milk and cookies for Santa
we can do that would you do that would
you do that for me Sammy leave some milk
and cookies
yep let me ask you have you all been
good boys and girls this year
have you been good yeah
[Music]
let me ask Mommy and Daddy Nicholas and
Tasha have they been good children this
year
they've been pretty good mostly mostly
pretty good I don't know that's sort of
that's rolling the dice we don't want to
do that too close to Christmas tell me
Nick Nicholas and Tasha how have they
been good have they been helping you out
they are very big helpers absolutely
okay well how do they help out Sammy and
Jonathan how do you help mommy and daddy
out around the house all right
do you pick up messes yeah no you pick
up
you helped pick up messes okay do you
put your toys away when you're done
playing with them
yeah oh that doesn't sound like you're
too sure that's a rule
that's all what we call a hard and fast
rule here at the North Pole we had an
accident with Blitzen and he he hurt his
back he tripped on a choo choo train so
it's very important that you pick up
your toys okay
all right now look I'm going to talk
with all of you as we do this now things
have changed
oh what was that
we're not sure oh well you know what
that's the same thing here we have we
have elves from all over the world I
have one I have well actually quite a
few who are mine because uh they're
looking for work but I don't understand
a word they're saying but my word the
hot chocolate is fantastic if a little
spicy so Sammy I'm going to speak with
you first you're you're six years old
now right
yep yeah and you know what Sammy I've
actually been hearing a lot about you do
you know who's been talking to me about
you
it's okay it's all good actually it's
your your instructor your coach he says
that you're actually doing really well
in Jiu Jitsu is that something you're
really excited about
yeah yeah you dude how many times a week
are you doing Jiu Jitsu Samuel
two two times a week oh boy that's great
that's great to get into something like
that because you can protect yourself
and more importantly you can protect
your little brother and your little
sister are you are you good you protect
your little brother and sister
yeah you keep them safe
well that's good we don't want you to be
a bully so let me ask you Samuel Sammy
what's what's your favorite move in Jiu
Jitsu do you have one that you use a lot
laughs
take that take down take down oh boy I
tell you what you you just do like a
blast double take down is that what you
do
yeah no you say no he says yes you know
we had actually we have an elf here who
actually he made All American
wow yes but it was in the 127 pound
division so after his collegiate career
well this was the only place for him so
let me ask you Sammy
what do you want for Christmas this year
do you still like you still like
building things online are you still
into Minecraft and then maybe in real
life with some Legos
yeah
yes okay what what else are you looking
for for Christmas I I remember you did
you did you write Santa this year or did
you just do it with your your parents
reached out to me but I I don't remember
if you wrote me a letter by snail mail
it'll be written say another letter yet
not yet okay well you know everything's
digital these days I remember somewhere
something about
uh gravitrax Pro marble run toys that is
is that about right
control school yeah you know it's okay
your your dad's usually in charge but
right now the big man's in town you
don't need to look to him for that you
can tell me directly this is one of
those times you can speak to Santa and
Nicholas says he can do his own thing so
what else is it that you want for
Christmas this year
Pokemon cards Pokemon cards you know
those were very popular a while back
then they went away now they're back I
really wish I would have invested but
Santa put a lot of his into beanie
babies so
yeah I'm really hoping for a comeback
with pogs so
Pikachu Pikachu and grab a tracks it is
then but you've been a good boy you
think that you really you've really
earned your keep for that these Pokemon
cards and the gravitrax
okay I can't tell who's saying I think
that's that's Jonathan saying yes am I
hearing that right yeah all right
now let me ask hey can Jonathan talk
with Santa is it going to be a lot of
gobbly [ __ ]
he could talk a little bit but it'll be
a lot of translating okay well you know
what hey hey Sammy Sammy this is a
chance to prove how much you help Mom
and Dad can you help me talk with
Jonathan
yeah you can help me talk with JoJo tell
me what does your little brother Jojo
what does he like to do what kind of
toys does JoJo like
oh Hot Wheels anything he likes
wrestling with you too right anything
that moves he's he's into action right
yeah okay now what about what about
cooking or play food does he is he still
enjoying doing that
yeah okay and and Jojo Jojo what what
else would you like do you does this
maybe ring a bell of ice just if I say
the word and this is something you want
just say anything
Nerf gun would you like a Nerf gun for
Christmas
oh then I guess it's just going to be
Tinker Toys
wow what do you think Sammy do you think
you you think your little brother would
like a Nerf gun
okay and he he might like something like
a like a marble Rush set too and maybe
some things to play kitchen with
yes okay all right well if you all think
you've been good enough I think that
Santa can maybe oh no he speaks
mom dad what what do you think uh what
do you what do you think Jonathan is is
most it changes so fast when they're
that age
yeah
he he definitely loves his cars and
Monster Trucks from Hot Wheels that is
probably number one for him oh so he's
all boy no for sure 100 100 boy you know
what it used to be we used to have toys
for boys toys for girls and well it's
still toys for boys toys for girls I
don't know how they do it over in in
Europe but we still do boy girl here at
the North Pole and I think that hot
wheels are a wonderful toy let me ask
now we have Billy over there so Sammy
Santa's really relying on you since
you're the one who's able to to talk
more what what do you think sad what do
you think Billy would like for Christmas
what does she do most
okay
would it be something she's a girl could
it be something like dolls cradles maybe
a princess castle maybe something like
that
you can answer whatever you think Bud
well you know what it's not really fair
Santa put a young boy on the spot as
tribute for what a little girl would
want and they haven't a clue I really
only know because I have a list
all right so look we have we have Billy
we have JoJo we have Sammy and I'm going
to be asking of course your Mom and Dad
we have we have Nicholas and uh and we
have Nicholas and you're there in
Maryland right
yep Nicholas and Tasha would you say
that these these children are uh they're
good enough that maybe these lists
should be uh something that Santa could
provide for them on Christmas Day whoa I
just I thought you're oh look at that
look at Jonathan I thought your father's
yeah I thought Nicholas's head was a
bear for a moment
what is that is that a bear or is that
is that a rabbit
it's a pig oh it's a pig they'll eat
anything you know
[Laughter]
yes well so will Mrs Claus but we won't
talk about that right now because a lot
of people you see this
all right I'm going to talk with Mommy
and Daddy for a bit do you do you want
to talk uh here adults or do you want to
however you want uh you little ones here
or do we want grown-up time
some grown-up time they're gonna go play
together I think okay all right so so
Sammy can you watch your can you watch
your little brother while I talk with
Mommy and Daddy
all right okay let me see you let me see
you take care of him now show Santa how
you take care of your brother
oh there we go oh look at that bye two
little ones be good Santa's going to be
visiting you this Christmas if you're
goodbye Sammy
bye Sammy take care of your brother
oh they seem I know that Jonathan
they're young they're not not able to
talk as much but Sammy really does seem
like a wonderful boy
he is yeah and I know that I know you
reached out here the North Pole this
year where Santa gives back and uh you
had a story that really really touched
touched Santa deeply and I I didn't want
to of course with the little ones bring
anything up that you weren't comfortable
with but I know you wanted to share your
story that you you went through here
these last couple of years
yeah
um with our our son Benny who
he we had Benny about two years after we
had Sammy
um so they were they were pretty close
in age
and when I was about 27 weeks pregnant
with him
we were supposed to be finding out if he
was a boy or a girl and we found out
that he
had very significant heart defects
um and at first we didn't really know
the extent of those we had to be sent to
a better Hospital more equipped for
Imaging and things like that
um
so once we we kind of got an idea of
just how extensive his heart defects
were you know they
weren't sure that he would even make it
to birth
um
and
you know I do have a lot of respect for
WVU Hospital in Morgantown
they did take very good care of us the
one the one qualm I have and it's not on
anyone in particular but you know we
made it pretty clear outright that
even if any wasn't going to have long
with us we we had no interest in
abortion just to put it playing
um and despite that we we still about
every other visit
I would have to field offers for
referrals of that kind and they even got
a phone call at least one time from a
clinic farther out in West Virginia
saying that they had received our
information and wanted to set up an
appointment and I had to tell them that
we're really not that was when that was
when Mama Bear kicked in oh yeah for
sure
um
I think I think they finally got the
point after a while and it's stopped
after that
um
we really
we really wanted to spend as much time
with him as we had with them we weren't
going to cut that time short for some
any reason
um but he did he made it to birth
and he was actually our biggest baby on
the other boy how big was Benny when he
was born he was still only six pounds
but he was the biggest out of all of
them okay
and he he had to be intubated at Birth
like with breathing too
um
but he did well I mean he had about a
week of adjusting they weren't sure
whether his pulmonary artery would
shrink or get too big or which way it
might go because baby's Hearts aren't
ready
wild and crazy and do all kinds of
things when they're born
um the one thing if I remember Benny had
his first open heart surgery was was he
about a week old is that to have that
okay that's that's got to be very scary
for for parents I can't imagine anything
more terrifying
and it was hard it was definitely very
hard
um we we didn't really love the surgeon
that we had at WVU he's since moved on
to a different hospital but
he was a really great guy just in
general
um but it was very nerve-wracking very
terrifying
but he he did a good job he made it
through and
recovery you know other than
weaning him off of all of the pain
medications
she really he really just did great
um about a month after that we got to go
home
um which apparently isn't normal usually
they still like to keep them until they
have their first actual like
reconstructive heart surgery where they
repair things sure yeah that's usually
how they do it so that's you're
fortunate to be able to do that yeah
when we're very blessed to have that
time at home as a family
um and then at three months old it was
time for him to have his next surgery
which was more of a reconstructive
surgery and
you know going into it even though he'd
already had one before it never
it never gets easier it's still
terrifying regardless
and
after he came out of that surgery he he
was doing okay for a couple of days
and then all at once his body started to
reject the new layout of his heart and
he caught rhinovirus which is just
common cold at the same time
um so he he rapidly deteriorated to the
point that they had to fly him to a
hospital in Pittsburgh where they were
better equipped to put him on ECMO
um which basically does all of his body
functions for him beating hard
breathing oxygenating blood things like
that
um
and they
I honestly not sure how many separate
surgeries they went in
to try to repair what they could and get
him off of ECMO
um every day that a person is it's a
blessing and a curse because ECMO you
know allows the body to rest sure and
recover but every day that someone's on
ECMO the likelihood of them coming off
decreases right it really is if it's a
difficult decision to make sometimes
when you're in that situation I know
it's
it's never an easy one yeah
um and he he went through countless
surgeries to try to
get him off of it
okay girl
that's okay don't you can just I think
she dropped her bottle there I think she
was looking is that in front of you Nick
Nicholas oh there you go she might
just is that what she's looking for
right there well I think she's just
looking for stuff to get into place oh
well that's that's true it's just pretty
much when they're that young Santa knows
it's making sure that they stay alive
that's pretty much what you have to do
is even Santa's little ones when he had
them every Outlet had to be back then we
had to use tack we didn't have all the
the polymer plugs it was just you know
you roll the dice with the world the way
it was
but yeah so Benny you went through this
with with Benny and I know that uh it
ended up getting obviously more more
serious
oh yeah so this surgery in particular he
actually did
um
he had a miracle on his surgeon at one
point said that he needed a miracle
and he got it he actually survived that
surgery and eventually came off ECMO and
he had suffered two strokes while on
ethno and and some other kind of
collateral issues from it but he he
spent a total of seven months in the
hospital us with him obviously
but he did recover from that and I think
it took about a year in total for him to
fully recover from all of that
um but once once he was able to come
home I mean he was just all eyes for
Sammy and as soon as he could keep up
with his brother he he was just attached
to him
yeah I could imagine and that's one of
those things they always want to be just
like big brother but sometimes you have
to take it easy when you're recovering
that's the hardest thing with little
ones
oh yeah
um and Benny was
spry he once he realized he could do
something trying to tell him not to was
not an option honestly
um so yeah he he kept up with his big
brother
with no problem
and you know we had we had a good couple
years of him just being a kid and
you know the we had lots of doctor's
appointments and checkups to just see
how he was doing and whatnot and they
would broach the topic that he was going
to need a certain other surgery at some
point sooner rather than later and we
we tried to push that as far as we could
one because we wanted him to recover as
much as possible from the last one
but also because we just we didn't know
that
surgery was the right choice
because of how the last one had gone
um
so we we just got as much time as we
could with him and it was a beautiful
joyful few years he was the most happy
little kid you'd ever meet regardless of
what he was going through that day
and he he touched a lot of people's
lives just because of how happy he was
just to be alive and be playing with his
brother
um the strength in that kid is
more than any person any adult I've ever
met
and as summer came around
in
was it 2019 or 2020
in 2021 it was atmosphere okay in 2021
summer came around and you know he
started wanting to come inside a lot
sooner and I mean he he could spend all
day outside even if it was zero degrees
out you know he
he loved being outside but at that point
he started wanting to come in even after
five or ten minutes he would spend all
day on the couch kind of just snuggling
up and it just wasn't like him at all
and we we noticed as time went on that
he got Bluer and Bluer because his heart
wasn't probably as much oxygen to the
rest of his body
so we knew that we we had to make a
choice to either to spend the time we
had with him
and not pursue surgery or to give him
this chance for better quality and
longer life with the surgery
um
and we did we did everything we could to
try to make sure that we were
making the right choice and
the right choice for him not selfishly
choosing for you know our own
desires obviously we want him with this
as long as possible but of course
oh we we got second opinions from other
hospitals to see what they thought and
they agreed that you know this surgery
was doable probably his best option and
it just it just wasn't
um they went to do the surgery and they
didn't actually get to do the surgery
they wanted to do they wanted to
actually create two ventricles from his
single ventricle but they couldn't do it
because his aorta just didn't allow it
um so they ended up redoing the same
surgery that he had previously that
didn't go well
um and again
right away his body just rejected it
um and they they did try to again repair
it like they did last time but at that
point his body had been through
so much that
there was really no catching up with the
damage that had been done so after a few
weeks
just everything started shutting down
one by one
um he ended up on dialysis and then they
couldn't keep him on dialysis because it
would leak just because his body was so
tired it couldn't even handle dialysis
so he he got sicker and sicker and it
got to the point where
we had to decide if you know he would
want to live a life of never getting out
of bed
if if his body even healed enough to get
to that point
um or if he was telling us that you know
he had fought enough and he was tired
and ready to let go and
it's a choice that
no parents obviously ever ever wants to
make and in making that choice we we
talked so long about you know making
sure that we were picking what Betty
wanted and even though Benny was free he
couldn't really talk so like he he
talked to us in his own way but he
wasn't a verbal Communicator the only
word he ever said was bi and happy
um well that's sort of providential
isn't it yeah
you know that he was you know that he
was happy let me I I know how difficult
this is and I think there are people out
there who will hear this and can only
imagine
what that kind of a choice is like for a
parent I truly can't imagine anything
more difficult but
you know what uh Nicholas and Tasha you
you did have
you did have another at least what
people presented to you as a choice
and I think it's the important one
that was that you chose to give little
Benny life
yes
that you chose and let me ask you this
despite everything that happened and I
can't imagine anything more difficult
Santa would go to the Gates of Hell
itself for his children as I know you
would
I would imagine that you don't regret
making that decision with Benny for a
moment
no no absolutely no regret for it
and I think that's a very powerful
example for people out there who will
often say that well this is how it's
supposed to be or you know they decide
that some people don't deserve to have a
chance and you you gave him a chance
yes seems like it
that was the least we could do for him
um and that's one of the many reasons we
we do like sharing his story is to give
anyone out there
in a position where they have
they're presented with this choice and
have a sick child that
it
it's a choice that exists but
the real choice is choosing to give your
child the chance that they want and if
they
don't make it they they didn't make it
on their own and if they do make it then
you have a beautiful time with them you
know
um
yeah we were very blessed to have him in
our lives I you know I I speak with
parents all over the world and obviously
this is an unfortunate situation that
happens or something similar to this and
never once never once have I spoken to
anyone who says that they regret
having that child in their life that
they regret that life as difficult as it
may be and I think that sometimes around
Christmas is
as difficult as things may be it's time
to
be thankful for the things we do have
and right now look you have a wonderful
family even if she's even if she's a
little troublemaker right there I'm sure
I'm sure that you're glad to have that
Troublemaker in your life for every
single every single electrical Appliance
she unplugs or
or chemicals she ingests that she's not
supposed to the young Santa had to have
his stomach pumped one time for what was
back then was Children's Tylenol it was
incredibly difficult I know how hard it
is but I also know that obviously this
is expensive and obviously you incurred
a lot of medical bills that were very
difficult for the family right
well we we were very blessed by living
in the smallest town we live in people
really rallied to support us and help
however they could
um between spaghetti benefits to
just donating out of their pocket
um we we had a significant
amount of support and well that's
fantastic your whole town rallied behind
you that's that's a real blessing and
you know that's one thing that a lot of
people when they talk about small town
America or Appalachia they they often
forget about the people and what they do
for each other I tell you the place
Santa Claus loves going least is New
York City
my my slate could be stranded right in
the middle of Sixth Avenue and no one
would bat an eye or help a wink but I
know that you're being very obviously
grateful and and positive and I I can't
tell you how much that means to everyone
I know watching and listening right now
but I also know how how difficult that
can be for a family and not just
obviously emotionally but the financial
toll it can take and now what you do
know is we've spoken before this you've
spoken with Santa's elves that Santa
will be taking care of all the Christmas
gifts this year for your little ones and
I'm very happy but there's something
that you don't know
your story touched us so much over here
at the North Pole that we actually would
like to I'd like to bring in my elf here
elf Riley to help you right now she can
show it to the camera but Santa's going
to have to show you this your family
this year with a check for fifty
thousand dollars
to help you reset
and to help your family as you get
through this Christmas season
and you went through a time that I can
only imagine most people couldn't even
couldn't even in the in their worst
possible scenario and I wish I could do
more but I can't I think you've done so
much more for us and sharing your story
I truly thank you
no thank you thank you
um if I could say one last thing if it's
one thing I promise you I'm good for it
I promise you that I am good for it
Santa actually got on the early train
with Bitcoin so I'm flushed I'm good
good now I am it's just an important
point to bring up whenever we talk about
Vinnie that you know I met a lot of
amazing families who
who were also staying at the Ronald
McDonald House which is an amazing
charity that I think if anyone does have
a means to give back is a great way to
give back
um but I made lifelong friends there and
UDA would be passed I one of the girls
that I'm closest to she said you know I
can't help but be mad at God for
letting these little kids be sick and
suffer so much and I told her
you know I I can't be mad at God at all
because God is the one that chose us to
be Benny's parents and put him in our
lives to begin with
and
regardless of the things that Benny went
through which was all part of God's plan
you know he
he was part of our lives and I I could
never be mad about that and in part of
his plan was to touch an astounding
amount of people's lives
and it
I could never be mad at God for giving
us such a beautiful thing in our lives
well I tell you what I think you've
touched a great many lives here today
and I know that you've touched everyone
here there's this has been a trend here
this
this day there's not a dry eye in the
house and I hope that what little we can
do here is a help to you and I tell you
what I do not say this
lightly those children are incredibly
blessed to have parents like you
Nicholas and Tasha and I don't think
that Benny could have asked for better
when it comes to parents I thank you and
I thank you so much for sharing your
story and I hope that people really
Ponder hard and not only not only listen
but take a moment and and be grateful
for the things they have and the people
in their lives Nicholas Natasha thank
you so much thank you thank you so much
I wish you both the merriest Christmas
and that will be well I don't know if we
do wire or Santa's not allowed on PayPal
anymore venmo they have a problem with
you know it's there's not enough
diversity at the North Pole but there's
also been enough sun I don't know what
they want from me so Nicholas and Tasha
the short family we wish you the best
Santa's going to take care of you this
year God bless you and thank you truly
from the bottom of my heart thank you
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas to you oh what a wonderful
family
[Music]
that's hot again
every time I it's hotter
it's like a Pop-Tart that's been in the
toaster for far too long it sticks to
your mouth like Napalm or agent orange
look I'm supposed to leave you here this
is the last time I'll see you this year
with
thoughts on Christmas and I don't know
that I can say it any better than the
families that have come before me but
I do think that everyone's having a
little bit of trouble these last couple
years I understand that some people have
had some rough goes some tough breaks
and sometimes it feels like that
Christmas miracle is just a little bit
further away than you were hoping for
and I want you to know that there are a
lot of people out there and maybe you
don't even know some you do but some
waiting in the wings
who are there to help make your Miracle
happen you may just need to reach out
many of us here have experienced it this
year to the point that we don't have
enough room for it with mugclub
forever.com and all all of you we thank
you from the bottom of our hearts and
support from Fantastic
fantastic Partnerships out there that
have helped us Santa's a Walther man as
you well know you have sent a crowd to
coco.com I genuinely
I'm giving this by aside from the fact
that it's scalding hot that's that's not
their fault
that's ours it is the best hot cocoa
I've ever what's the difference between
hot chocolate and hot cocoa does anyone
know milk fat I don't know it's very
cuddly it's good
it's good
so I would hope for all of you out there
right now I understand and it's very
easy to complain it's very easy to see
how difficult cold Cutthroat maybe
selfish the world has become
you're not wrong in seeing that in the
world Santa sees it too but
doesn't Christmas make that coldness
just a little bit more warm
doesn't Christmas maybe help us all to
treat each other a little less Cut
Throat with a little more empathy
and doesn't it maybe turn
a frown and a tear into a smile and a
hug
and if it doesn't
well put down the politics for a little
bit put down your news apps and go make
it happen yourself there's probably
someone in your life who needs it and I
don't know exactly when I'll be seeing
you again because I don't know if you
know about this but at the North Pole
there's a lot of
well there's some red tape this time of
year
but Santa can keep track of you and
don't let us lose touch with you by just
entering your email at mugclub
forever.com that's what makes all of
this work possible and the help that we
can provide as small as it may be a drop
in the bucket of the world this
Christmas season
it's all supported by you
and we appreciate your continued support
and we promise that we won't let you
down if you enter in your email at
mugclub forever.com
you won't receive any spam
you won't receive mailing lists being
sold to other people you might receive a
confirmation to make sure you want to be
in that list so that you aren't sold a
bunch of
nfts
and oversized foam hands that's not what
Christmas is all about
I mean I think I have some on my list
but this thing is just useless at this
point it's just a screed from someone's
insane Lamentations Merry Christmas
we'll see you when we see you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
traveling
[Music]